i'm in iz la parole est à madame marine
breugnot merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre je ne
reviendrai pas ici sur les circonstances
connues de tous du drame qui a touché
nice en juillet dernier l'implication de
chacun dans la prise en charge des
familles endeuillées a été bien réel
pourtant au delà de 86 personnes qui ont
perdu la vie des centaines de familles
peuvent être considérées comme des
victimes de cet attentat
je pense aux blessés bien entendu mais
aussi à tous ceux qui ont subi un
dommage psychologique
en ce qui concerne les victimes de
dommages corporels
les critères d'indemnisation ont été
clairement établis et sont
incontestables pourquoi des provisions
n'ont elles pas été accordé dans
l'urgence
je vais vous parler d'une niçoise que
j'ai rencontrés qui est profondément
traumatisé par ce qu'elle a vécu au delà
des dommages physiques subis
heureusement le ccas de la ville de nice
à pallier les manques de l'état en lui
accordant une aide pour subvenir à ses
besoins immédiats mais qu'attendez vous
qu'attendez vous pour définir le statut
de victime psychotraumatiques pour enfin
envisager une indemnisation
tous les intervenants associations de
victimes structures publiques
nous sommes tous dans la tente de cette
définition pour permettre une
reconstruction personnelle à ceux qui
souffrent or vous en conviendrez
les huit millions et demi d'euros versés
à ce jour selon vos propres chiffres
sont dérisoires par rapport aux 400
millions d'euros annoncée est nécessaire
que dire aux personnes blessés dans leur
chair comme dans leur âme que le
gouvernement encore besoin de temps
monsieur le premier ministre
au delà de toute considération partisane
ma question est double
quand disposeront nous enfin d'une
définition précise du statut de victime
psycho traumatiques et comment garantir
une indemnisation individualisé dans les
plus brefs délais du court 10 subie par
tous elle secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'aide aux victimes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés madame la députée
marine brégnier je vous remercie de
penser et c'est en cette période de
commémoration de la mémoire des victimes
des attentats je vous remercie de penser
à leurs souffrances et je vais vous dire
ici que les victimes que je rencontre
chaque jour et en particulier à nice où
je me suis rendu quatre fois et où je
retourne jeudi me disent évidemment
qu'elles ont besoin d'abord et avant
tout de la reconnaissance de l'état et
cette reconnaissance passe par un
accompagnement psychologique par un
service public de l'aide aux victimes et
j'ai installé à nice le tout premier
comité local de suivi des victimes qui
est un service public sur mesure et dont
chaque département de france disposera
avant la fin du quinquennat
et donc ces victimes ont bien entendu
besoin d'un accompagnement psychologique
et le gouvernement a mis en place la
gratuité totale des soins psychologiques
à nice où 26 équivalents temps plein
supplémentaires ont été octroyés à
l'hôpital et sachez également que sur
production bien entendu d'un certificat
médical établi par un spécialiste
toute personne qui n'aurait pas été sur
la zone de danger aura droit à une
indemnisation du fgti alors quelques
chiffres même si en matière de victimes
les questions financières ce n'est pas
la première chose qui est demandé mais
quand même 2276 demandes d'indemnisation
ont été déposées aujourd'hui et 11,8
millions d'euros ont été versés la
majorité des demandes étaient traitées
et enfin ce que demandent les victimes
c'est la reconnaissance en france en
europe et à l'international et j'ai
organisé la france a organisé hier la
première conférence internationale de
l'aide aux victimes
à laquelle trente pays ont participé
dont dix ministres et qui pour la
première fois
lance une politique européenne et
internationale de l'aide aux victimes
c'était aussi la demande des
associations de victimes avec lesquelles
je travaille chaque jour
merci la parole